j'écoute les parlementaires aient l'air
et ps qui s'exprime avec grande émotion
sur le sort des retraités agricoles
ils ont été en charge de ces questions
là pendant 20 ans ou 25 ans kim a
méprisé pendant 20 ou 25 ans les
retraités agricoles
c'est eux parce que c'est très facile
quand on est dans l'opposition de venir
donner des leçon et des leçons de morale
y compris sur les retraites agricoles ce
qui l'attend aujourd'hui est de
désistement c'est très clair c'est que
le gouvernement a décidé d'une grande
réforme des retraites à l'horizon 2019
donc et pas de reporter aux calendes
grecques tout le monde sait que cette
semaine du gouvernement attendre 2020
pour revaloriser notre éthique chez nous
avons une collègue au groupe géraldine
banier qui est sidéré culture et qui
connaît bien ces questions plusieurs
d'entre nous se sont exprimés pour dire
il faut aller vite il faut qu'on tienne
l'engagement du président de la
république simplement il faut le faire
dans le calendrier minimum qui est celui
d'une un débat global sur les retraites
le président de la république a voulu
que les régimes puissent converger que
pour un euro cotisé
même si ça sera un peu plus compliqué
que ça pour un euro cotisé on a 1 euros
de pension de retraite qu'il ya une
équivalence des régimes de retraite et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on aura ce débat
pour revaloriser les retraites agricoles
oui c'est injuste personne ne dit le
contraire simplement vous pouvez pas
dire les retraités agricoles en 2019
et puis il ya aussi des conjoints
collaborateurs d'artisans qui sont dans
cette situation là et donc on va égrainé
et il s'est juste toutes ces questions
là on va égrener des choses sans
regarder la globalité on reporte pas aux
calendes grecques le gouvernement faire
maintenant pour dire 2020 pourquoi 2020
parce que la réforme elle doit se faire
en 2018 2019 sur les réformes des
retraites et donc première année
d'application à partir de 2020 et nous
tiendrons nous au gouvernement le
discours que je vous tiens là qu'est il
faut revaloriser les retraites agricoles
pour que l'engagement sera tenue en tout
cas nous veillerons à ce que
l'engagement soit tout simplement dans
le calendrier qu'elle notait pas le
calendrier de ceux qui réinventent un
calendrier alors que pendant vingt ans
il revient ça ne va creuser le fossé
entre le gouvernement les retraités
je crois pas on sait qu'on a un problème
sur la table sur les retraités agricoles
il faut qu'on avance sur ce sujet là on
le verra au moment des retraites je
pense qu'il faut qu'on trouve un système
qui soit juste pour tout le monde et qui
fasse que les gens soient pas dans des
situations de distorsions comme les
agriculteurs de son un mot sur la
méthode employée par le gouvernement qui
a de nouveau eu recours au vote bloqué
vous le déplorez non parce qu'à un
moment quand vous êtes face à vous des
gens alors c'est jamais agréable d'avoir
recours à des méthodes qui sont les
méthodes un peu contraignante que dont
dispose le gouvernement
simplement il ya un gouvernement ils
décident dé ses orientations avec sa
majorité sur la réforme des retraites
on voit bien aussi vous faut dire les
choses vont je vois ceux qui
s'offusquent et tout le monde est
d'accord sur la question des retraites
agricoles pour il faut pas s'offusquer
comme ça en sachant très bien que de
toute façon la volonté c'était de faire
passer à toute force et dans le
calendrier qui était leur le texte nous
on avait un autre calendrier vont
accepter aussi ça